if you go on a construction site in
America right now and you say everybody
that's not originally born in America
has to leave You' lose the whole job
damn near every man out there Spanish
Guatemalans panamanians Mexicans and
they're coming in and taking the jobs
that Americans don't want and I think
the average American is growing up in a
world that he feels like he failed if
he's not drop shipping from a beach we
live in a world where you can shake your
ass on Tik Tok and make more money than
the guy that PVE the road for me to get
here if you see a guy in work boots
findy his lunch you tell him Hey listen
I'm a part of this campaign called B man
the beard would you please let me buy
you lunch or would you please let me
cover that for you would mean a lot to
me because I'm in construction because I
work construction my whole life I have a
heart for Man Without these guys man the
world doesn't run I just want to
Champion these guys more because I don't
think they get the credit they deserve
and I don't think people realize how
important they are